there are critics who argue that popular
culture is dumbing down would you say
that's true reflected in the film and
television that's out today or no I
think I'm on the fence about that it
really depends on what movies or TV are
very popular as upon you know if you're
talking about you know when I see movies
like you know transformers or like this
glut of superhero movies now I go uh-huh
you know it's got to me it's kind of a
negative thing for audiences you know
I'm kind of sad that that audiences are
you know responding to that and making
the movie successful which just brings
about more movies you know studios are
all about making movies that make money
and so I understand why they keep making
him but for me I'm kind of getting a
little tired of that um that said
doesn't mean that there's not good
storytelling out there I think what's
great about the fact that there's more
avenues for stories and I'm glad that
the netflix and Amazons and and our and
online all stuff is opening up and the
golden age of television I think there's
much much more great TV being written
now that there was before so all that
gives me confidence about the state of
storytelling today so I'm kind of happy
about that but but i think you know if
you look at the history of entertainment
there's always been both sides you know
so I'm kind of in the middle I won't say
yes we're dumbing down or we getting
better but you know it's both as it
always been do you think we're making
more complex characters these days I
think so I mean one of the things about
storytelling is that we respond to knew
we were conditioned to respond to new
things to pay attention to new things
that's what we like high concept part of
it is like what i call the uniquely
familiar we you have to come up
something unique we've never seen before
that's all so familiar you know there's
this joke about the executive saying
yeah just give me the same thing only
different right probably heard this
before that's what it means we want to
we want to see stories that are
different but familiar it's all the same
thing but in a different way different
go so the thing with characters is that
you know as we see more more characters
in more stories we have to come up with
something that's new we have to come up
with new characters or new traits or new
goals or and that's getting harder and
harder and harder so because of that I
think they're becoming more complex I
think we're because of all the
entertainment that's been done good
storytellers are aware of that and by
the way to answer your previous question
about beginning writers one of the
things that the reason we see a lot of
material we've seen before you know kind
of like cliche stuff is because they're
not aware of what's been done before so
part of your education as a writer is
really to know what's been done before
so you really got to be very
knowledgeable about you have to be kind
of be a geek about this about knowing
all the movies that been done before and
all the TV that's been done before and
all the comic books have been done
before so that you know when you create
something you try to avoid that come up
with something unique now there's
nothing new Under the Sun everything has
been done before but this there's always
I'm always amazed I'm always excited
when uh when there's a new concept or
something like you know my god that's
such that's brilliant you know because
it's familiar but it's unique you know
so it's it's you know so there's always
that it's all about creativity and
originality and that's really a big part
of being an artist you have to be
original that's why we respond to love
it but it's too close to King Lear sorry
you know that right yeah yeah but look
what they done with King Lear right i
mean they you can modernize it and you
know and that's in it that's a unique
angle on its own
you